(upbeat, exciting music)
- Avocados are awesome!
- I love avocados, I used
to not like avocados.
- We love avocados.
- Avocados are good on some things.
- What?
- They taste like nothing!
- I feel like when you eat avocado,
it's normally savory.
Like, it's normally
whipped, some kind of meal,
some kind of entree, so
it's hard for me to think
about drinking it.
- I don't know.
Now that I see it, I kinda wanna throw up.
- It looks like ice cream.
- Oh, it smells like avocado.
- Just like avocado.
- Smells like memories.
- Avocado cheers.
- I like it.
- I can't tell if I like it or not.
- You do.
- I mean, I think I do.
Yeah, when I think about it, I do.
- This is as bad as I
thought it was gonna be.
Tastes like grass.
- It's like the texture of, like, yogurt.
- It's like a vanilla milkshake
with a tint of avocado.
- I'll even say, like, a fruity milkshake.
A really, really just, mild one.
- Where are you getting that from?
- I don't know.
I like it the more I drink it.
It keeps getting better and better.
- My brain is going
crazy because it's like,
wait, is that ice cream?
- Yeah!
- If they threw this is into
halo-halo instead of, like,
ice cream on top, then
that would be pretty bomb.
- Is there avocado ice cream?
- I'm pretty sure.
- Avocado ice cream.
Is there that?
- Ten out of ten, would goop again.
- Yeah, and if I ever give
birth to an offspring,
totally gonna make them
think this is ice cream
for about twelve years.
- Just lie to them?
- Yeah, just be like,
this is a sweet treat.
- Avocado freak, do the avocado.